thank you
foreign
[Music]
yo
what's goody hot breath of Earth
one second one second one second
what is goody my friends how y'all doing
out there
there we go the music just shifted
I was just looking at my hair right
there
right there right there
right there a little curl for you there
well come on in everyone we about to do
our weekly
live
q a
right here
at the hot breath Comedy Network if
you're watching live I see you
comment let me know where you're
watching from
I'm about to bring on my co-host
Yoshi so and we gonna jump in
two to get in and this is gonna be a
goodie my friends I'm very excited about
this
and if anybody is in the
East Tennessee area
this weekend
your boy is headlining
Blue Ridge comedy club in Bristol
Tennessee
this Friday and Saturday so if you're in
the area
East Tennessee that may be near Virginia
as well you know Bristol
uh Tennessee holla at you bizoy I love
to meet you this
it's a clean comedy weekend at the club
that was actually put together
by hot Brethren bill ketron so if you're
in your own comedy scene and there's a
comedy club there or another venue and
you like to produce a show together yo
holla at your boy I would love love love
to do a show together
I've done several shows Bristol
Tennessee goodness just a few months ago
I was out in Oregon
doing a show with a hot breather out
there so
if you're interested hit me up in the
DMS at Joel byerscomedy
on social media or at hopbreathpod as
well you can hit me up or on Facebook
but let's talk Cyrus Zed from Toronto yo
Cyrus speaking of doing shows I actually
want to perform in Toronto this year
literally
um so if you know of shows or venues or
if there's a comedy festivals happening
there or anything like that
let's talk for real for real because I'm
I'm literally trying to plan a trip to
Toronto this year and I'm not even
kidding because I think that's um
some specials going on up there that uh
I'd like to dip my toes into
bring some comedy some feel-good comedy
up there
so let's uh Cyrus let me know in the
comments let me know um
if that's something you think we can
make happen and let's talk about it I
know there's several
hot breathers up there in the Toronto
area
yeah I agree Cyrus yep we just had um
um
Ava Alexander who is actually based in
Quebec right now but her show Kickback
or not not Quebec sorry Montreal
um and her show Kickback actually got
picked up by JFL and I think she just
did one in Toronto and she was talking
about how great comedy is in Canada but
also that
um Toronto is like the Hollywood of
Canada so
Cyrus send me
um if you could there buddy send me a
message
on
uh Facebook or Instagram or something
I'd love to talk more details um because
I know Bob Kirk another hot breather
based up there in Toronto so I know
there's a lot of hot breath love
that we could spread while we're up
there so
um several hot breathers up there in
Toronto that's why I want to get a trip
up there because I've been meaning to do
it and I this is the year to do it as
well
because my wife also wants to go up
there so I think it would be a good
family trip as well so help me help you
help us all right
on our Facebook group Rick Roberts good
to see you there buddy
hello there Rick
we do this q a every Tuesday Rick
we live stream this q a on our YouTube
channel I have my co-host Yoshi so who
comes straight from carpool
to be a part of this
every single Tuesday
I'm gonna fix my camera here oh
let me get that out of the way
but it's good to see you there Rick
cool beans
so as we're getting in here
go ahead and start posting your
questions
if you would like
as people are coming in here we were
just talking about how this weekend I
will be headlining Blue Ridge Comedy
Club
in Bristol Tennessee all weekend Friday
and Saturday so if anyone
watching this is in that area
holla at your boy would love to meet you
I know we have some hot breathers coming
out
sorry I was just pouring a little
water for you there this hot breath mug
that's good gin right there
gotta hold that of that moonshine going
on right there
but anyone that area I would love love
love to meet you
or if you know of shows or venues in
your area would love to do shows with
you out in your area as well so holla
awesome Cyrus said he'll DM me on IG
looking forward to it there buddy
uh mookie G greetings greetings my
friend
Jared Kroll said International Joel yeah
so I have it performed uh the farthest I
performed was Japan
born in Japan a few years ago
um
and all over this country I've been up
to JFL but I haven't been
um
uh
uh I haven't performed I was up there I
was a writer for the first roast battle
and craziness actually Miss Pat was on
it
and
um she's been on the podcast she's been
a nice mentor and she actually took me
up there to help her write jokes uh for
the roast battle it was that was the
first season ever and they taped it up
there at Just for Laughs incredible
experience dude
she was like the belle of the ball up
there and that was before
she's now Miss Pat Miss Pat that was
like before her book and all that but
they were she was still to battle the
ball up there so that was really cool to
see
and just all the fun behind the scenes
stuff
um so I have not performed in Canada
until this year and we're changing that
we're changing that
by golly
all right
all right we got some questions coming
in here I'm scrolling I'm seeing some
questions here
I'm singing some questions here I'm
seeing I'm seeing some questions here
oh I just hit the wrong button there
beautiful
so I see mookie you got a question and
Cinema quirks got a question awesome
all right
so let's see Cinema quirks in your
opinion who's better Chappelle or prior
bruh
better I don't know who's better or not
I mean this is a political answer I
guess but comedy is subjective so who's
great to one person may not be to
another and vice versa comedy
preferences are as personal as food
so some people love onions other people
hate onions same thing with cilantro and
so on so
who's better
they're just different they're just
different but tell you what I'm gonna do
I'm gonna bring Yoshi on
and we're going to talk about it here so
just one second my friends
we gonna
bring him on in just one Segundo un
Segundo por favor
you ready Yoshi
all right everyone we can officially
begin keep posting your questions in the
live chat I see you Mookie
posting your question I see you Cinema
quirks I see you I crack myself up
and now
y'all about to see the one and only
straight off the carpool lane
give it up for Yoshi so everyone give it
up for Yoshi
let go carpooling baby
what happened
how are you brother I'm doing good are
your is one of your mic cords loose are
any of them loose Mike cord hold on let
me check it just sounded kind of choppy
in my back how about this how about this
how about this okay cool it sounded like
something was like loose and it was kind
of uh just choppy a bit but maybe
you may be good now all right I think
I'm in there yeah you sound good yeah
oh very nice awesome so we already got
some questions popping in here
but how you doing before we start this
off you good you need a minute you need
to take a breath
transition It's been a
you know I mean I feel like these last
couple weekends have just been good
comedy weekends I feel like we've been
busy you and I have worked like we've
just been grinding and so like I feel
like the grind is like in full effect
and the things that we've been grinding
about are like comments or fruition so
yeah it's been a good week I can't
complain about anything dude so it's
just been a good week of Comedy
enjoying the stuff that I'm writing
looking forward to more stuff got book
shows you know filming a comedy special
working on that we hold new accountable
fam we hold you accountable hey it's
getting there it's getting there I'm
thinking about the venue and sort of the
cameras and all the other stuff so yeah
man I'm I'm excited about it
well just High you know I you may you
may just know someone who has filmed the
comedy special so you can I may I may
you you made it I may and I'm not the
only one you know I'm sure you know
several people who have so yeah sure
yeah so it's um yeah you don't have to
do it alone
absolutely yeah yeah which is what we're
doing here nothing alone where comedians
helping comedians is that theme song
rolls in as we get into this
q a
[Music]
Yoshi and I had some great shows this
past week Yoshi headlined a show we did
together killed it
it was fun that was a super fun show and
we're here to help y'all do the same in
your own comedy careers and whatever
your goals are so welcome to our weekly
q a we do every Tuesday live streamed on
our YouTube channel
yeah yeah we are full-time comedians
here to help you do the same if that's
what you aspire to do absolutely here's
my favorite thing about this weekend
about that show that we did together
so this is a show this I think it's
important to know like there's different
ways you can do shows but this is a show
that Joe and I both produce together Joe
hosts the show and I put the comments
Joel sorry Joel hosts the show what
what
do we all look the same all you white
people look and sound the same so it's
fine
so Joel hosts the show and I uh get the
rest of the comedians oh and I just
heard thunder so just saying if anything
cuts out that means my power cut out I
just want everyone to know
because it's happening as as we were
doing the show and we did the show and
it was the you know we can say this was
one of those shows that's like it's like
the it's a venue setup where we get tips
from the audience and the audience
itself is the one that gives us the tips
and that's how we pay The Comedians and
we were like oh this is the best tips
we've ever got and we're like why do you
think that is and it just came down to
one thing The Comedians were hilarious
like quality of the show yep the quality
of the show was just high and so
something to remember is you always want
to put high quality shows together
to get the kind of results that you want
because they stayed I mean I think the
show is 90 minutes pretty long for a
comedy show
we had four Comedians and then I closed
out so it was a pretty like good like
variety of comics that we put on the
show but I think that quality helped
people like oh we got more than what we
bargained for
sprinkle in the tip money so I think
it's also just I wanted to make sure I
bring that up that quality helps you get
the kind of things that you want from
your comedy
yep yep and we go into uh actually the
next few weeks I'm gonna be out of town
so we actually pre-recorded a few type 5
podcasts where we dive into
quickly in a few episodes they're like
five to seven minutes long but Yoshi and
I pre-recorded a few where we're
actually diving a little bit deeper and
more specific into certain topics that
we get asked about a lot and producing
your own show is one that we're going to
be releasing
um over these next few weeks as I am out
of town so we won't be doing these live
streams and um that's something we talk
about is we've talked about here before
is like well one co-producing your show
is like if you can co-produce it that's
the best like I was doing I was doing
these shows alone at first like at these
two breweries that we co-produced
together at now and I was just like yo I
need Yoshi yo Yoshi holla at your boy
like comedy's supposed to be fun and I
can tell you a great way to challenge
that fun very quickly is to produce your
own show alone it can be done
it's being done by several comedians but
like for me I just know like I just I'm
willing to yeah
for sure and I think it's leaning into
what you're good at when Jordan was like
hey uh I Don't Like wrangling Comics
yeah yeah I was like oh that's one of my
favorite Parts I got you right and so we
partnered and we're like okay I'll
Wrangle the comics you host the show and
I think it just worked out in that way
because to your point
we found the strength that we're both
good at and we leveraged it for the show
itself and now both successful shows we
do it on a regular consistent basis so
yeah I think when in doubt try to find a
partner that can help you do the thing
that maybe you're not
you you don't enjoy doing because you
want to enjoy the part you want to enjoy
the comedy part and I enjoy producing a
lot I love producing comedy
and another good point about producing a
quality show is uh quality like word
travels when something is quality so the
show you and I co-produce on Saturday
um it went really well and then the next
day a friend of the brewery that we did
that show at dm'd me and was like oh I
heard you do this show over here we'd
love to do one at our place like the in
the show the show Saturday was a a home
run and the reason was again
quality show quality lineup the
headliner absolutely destroyed it people
are like yes more of that so I think I
think we're catching stride here you
know I think it's a lot of trial and
error but I I feel like we're definitely
catching stride here
yeah I like that
yay yay yeah so it's a fun thing yeah
about um
co-producing shows so we'll have it
we'll have like a type 5 podcast about
that in on the next few weeks if you all
to enjoy and just apply for yourselves
but uh yeah you know comedy's comedy's
working and you your boy's gonna be in
East Tennessee at Bristol Comedy Club
all weekend this past weekend this
upcoming weekend
May 19th and 20th that was put together
by hot breather Phil ketron so y'all
listening
yeah I'm telling you reach out to us
message us if you want to do a show
together
Phil reached out to me and was like
would you be interested in headlining
this comedy club uh say less fam so now
we're doing this whole clean comedy week
in there he was on the news promoting it
and all sorts so listen
yeah we're here to work we're full-time
working comedians we want to work with
y'all we want to meet y'all we want to
help y'all
as much as you are enjoying this show so
let's don't hesitate to reach out
seriously
yeah I like that a lot
um so we got some questions coming in
and uh real quick while this is on
now that we're talking about type five
and whatnot Jerry asked the details on
the type 5 product which we used to do
something called the type 5 accelerator
where we would help comedians develop a
five minute set in a month
and it was like a weekly thing we would
do where we would all meet every week
and people would perform and get
feedback from us
in a very like detailed and Hands-On way
and then there'd be like a graduation
show where we bring in the CEO of World
Series of Comedy who gives feedback as
well
um and we did it for we did it for a
while and then you know we're
we're just you know we're working
comedians on ourselves and Yoshi has a
family and we do this live stream and a
lot of other things so it just kind of
anything Yoshi and I do we want to
be mindful we want to put everything we
have into everything we do like we don't
for anything to become like passive or
feel like an obligation and we knew that
has pandemic was ending and our
schedules were getting busier we want to
make sure anything we do
especially anything Comics pay for
because we know how valuable money is
the comedians that we want to make sure
that we are like under promising and
over delivering so that's something we
did for a while that we just kind of
weren't really quite able to do as much
anymore yeah for sure and yeah I mean if
we do it again I promise you we will let
you know because yeah that that type
five was like I feel like we got
comedians to just gold with their
material oh dude it was wild yeah it was
it was like deep like we would
with all the comedy and all the comics
of just like getting them talking about
their voice their stage presence
everything to attach them to get to sort
of really not having just a
a hot five like we called it the type
five like this was showcase ready
material for you to perform in front of
Bookers so you can be like oh I want to
work here at this club that that was the
big time focus of that type 5
accelerator yeah for sure and Jack Allen
in the comments said that type 5
accelerator started my comedy Journey so
yeah Jack was great he was actually
across the pond he would be up at like
midnight attending the class yeah very
funny y'all very very funny yeah yeah we
we still have on our website
hopperthmedia.com like classes and
workshops and such free audio to enjoy
and uh get value from but for the type 5
accelerator it's if we do one you guys
will definitely be the first to know
um but uh thanks for thanks for asking
there Jerry
um so let's yeah let's let's get into
these other questions my friends
and uh if y'all are enjoying this hit
that hit that thumbs up button on the
live stream so the peeps can
so the algorithm can show us a little
more love you know and if you're
listening to the podcast go subscribe to
our YouTube channel and join our
Facebook group and subscribe to our
email list while you're at it as well
just go ahead and do all the things for
all this amazing free content that you
get every single week and did we mention
it's free
because our wives should do every single
week
um
oh and Mary Baker said she's looking
forward to seeing me in Bristol that's
very exciting yes awesome man I'm
excited dude
all right so next up we have Cinema
quirks and y'all just remember it's
thundering and looks like it's storming
here
so for whatever reason I will not
manifest it but I just want you all to
be aware
um
that if anything cuts out it's because
God
or Yahweh
or the universe or whatever you want to
say
um deemed it so so Cinema quirks
speaking of gods two comedy Gods head to
head and your opinion
who's better Chappelle
or Pryor
[Music]
I mean
I you know if you had to pick one if
somebody put something
sort of you know made you had to choose
one it was like oh I'm gonna take your
kids away you gotta choose between this
right uh
uh I would have to go with
prior
that's a special
that he did I think
can stand the test of time like I I
don't know any other
comedian that can tell the story about
what they went through
after they went through it like he did
and then bring you in into his world
like Richard Pryor did like Master
storyteller
amazing at the jokes amazing at the
physicality
yeah I mean just that that prior special
alone is which one the
um live on Sunset in the red in the suit
yeah yeah where he bombed he bombed the
first taping of that did you know that
yeah yeah yeah I heard about it yeah I
heard you bombed the first taffy in the
first payment that he bombed and had to
come back the next night and re-tape it
yeah he left early he walked off the
stage the first time yeah
which is wild to think that that was
even possible given what that final
product was because that was an amazing
special
just offer that alone I I'd have to give
it to to Pryor
it
honestly I want to argue with you for
the sake of entertainment but like
I want to argue with you that would that
would be fun like there's a podcast
called taste buds where they just argue
about different foods like what's better
Oreos or Chips Ahoy and stuff so that
would be fun just to argue what
comedians are better
um Dave Chappelle
is
I feel like he's had more of a cultural
impact though I feel like he's been in
the Zeitgeist more I feel like what he's
done he's had some personal things but
the Chappelle show
is one thing that just like I don't
think Richard Pryor he had the Richard
Pryor Show but he didn't have anything
as culturally impactful as Chappelle's
Show and the fact that this dude
Chappelle drops what was it three
Netflix specials just like back to back
to back just like straight up 50 for 50
mil
yeah yeah yeah so you bring up a really
good argument you bring up a really good
argument from a cultural impact
perspective right what Chappelle has
done with first of all the Chappelle
show probably will go down as probably
the best sketch show of all time
I I have a hard time trying to rank
something above that when it comes to
sketch shows just as a collective right
now if they had more than maybe you
could say that there was other stuff but
like
Chappelle like I mean honestly best
sketch shows I think of all time is
Chappelle Show and key and peel uh yeah
Mr shows up there as well so very true
it was a good one right like the three
seasons of Chappelle Show
were I if I'm not mistaken the best
selling DVDs of all time like in terms
of like
from the numbers that I remember seeing
no one has ever been like from a comedy
perspective it wasn't sold in CD form
but it was like the best-selling DVD of
all time
like and part of it I think was the
Allure the fact that he left afterwards
the cultural impact that it had on
Comedy in general and then he wasn't
doing comedy years afterwards
you know what I'm saying and then came
back and sold out Radio City Music Hall
like nine times in a row yeah right so
to your point you make a really good
point that there it's hard to not give
Chappelle his flowers given the type of
cultural impact that he would have so I
think this is one of those things you
know I'd compare it to the to the LeBron
Michael Jordan uh conversation yeah and
that's what Cyrus said in the comments
was this is just like yeah comparing
Lebron and uh yeah so I I personally
believe LeBron is the best basketball
player of all time but I completely
understand why there's so many people
that love what they saw when they were
during the time of Michael Jordan
there's not many young people I would
say anyone who's like 30 or probably 40
and younger who would say that Jordan
was the better version was the best
basketball player because they never got
to see Jordan like that most people just
know what they see and right now
Chappelle is kind of killing it from a
cultural Zeitgeist perspective and you
don't know the impact that Pryor had
beforehand so I could see it in both
kind of ways but yeah I mean that is a
hard thing I would say I'd give it to
Chappelle from a cultural impact
perspective because I feel like we're
also at the midst of how we think about
all the conversations which I think on
trans issues pronouns freedom of speech
all these things are all part of sort of
the cultural Zeitgeist right now and
he's kind of at the top of the food
chain when it comes to Comedy so there's
that element of well as well that I
think he's just mastery
so you're not going to defend prior
you're just going to say I see you Joel
you have anything to defend I I don't
have anything to fit I I see you like
that's it's it's a solid argument dude
and I I will say stand up to stand up
though Stand Up is so personal and
preference it's like a food preference
you know like some people love cilantro
and other people hate it like me
personally I love the more personal I
love the more storytelling side of
things so when when this question came
up my brain went to Prior but you said
prior so I thought well let me not go to
Prior and see what we can cook up here
for the hot breath of Earth but stand up
to stand up I prefer Richard Pryor for
the sake of it's just it is that raw
storytelling autobiographical
incredibly personal incredibly true
and and he was on the Forefront of a lot
of the freedom of speech stuff that now
Chappelle gets to benefit from so
absolutely stand up to stand up I my
preference is prior if I have to pick
one uh but I mean they're both yeah you
can't go wrong with it either for sure
both of goats yeah yeah for sure yeah
absolutely yeah for sure
oh we have Amy Brown in here from ATL
was goody fam what up Jeff Arnold said
hey from Tampa good to see you there
Jeff oh we we ouch yeah so good question
there
that's a I like that question though I
like that question there Cinema quirks I
like um
more just comedy questions in general I
like getting into the educational stuff
but even just like what do you think of
yeah X verse y or what is next for
comedy or you know uh what napar gatzi
is doing with his YouTube channel is
very interesting with producing his own
not only podcasts but original comedy
specials he's about to release like his
version of don't tell comedy
um there's a lot of um Eliza Schlesinger
is doing the same with 800 pound gorilla
where she just released like a showcase
show where she's like profiling some of
her favorite up-and-coming comedians
there's a lot of interesting things
happening right now
um Beyond just educational stuff that I
enjoy talking about so
just say it for you know as we do these
q and A's they don't all have to be
educational if you don't want
um
but it's whatever y'all want to ask
yeah we'll fight if we have to
hold on
there's a boxing Bell yeah
I wonder uh mookie G said what are some
good ways to get booked across the
country not necessarily in comedy clubs
uh well I'll say first
if you're not in our Facebook group join
our Facebook group which is linked in
the description of this episode and post
a city that you want to go to and most
likely in the over 6 000 people on our
Facebook group someone in there may be
able to help you out or search that City
on Facebook and there's like coming to
Nashville coming to Atlanta groups to
where you can post in there and people
will give you booking info that's a
that's just a quick one off the top of
the Dome there
I mean it's using your network more than
anything else because you know we've
said it many of times the majority of
the way that you're going to get booked
for comedy is through other Comedians
and it's also just playing the
professional game like if you're gonna
send something out to people and be like
hey I'm coming through the city send
your best clip uh send out something
that represents you be respectful be
like hey don't just be like I'm here
tomorrow give it time give them some
time to try to help help you out
and then also I think the biggest thing
is like reciprocate that same kind of
love when those people come to the city
as well so I think that's super
important to just like we're all a
community here and we're all trying to
get that stage time trying to you know
get that love trying to make sure that
you know people see us so just be wary
not wary but like be conscious that if
you help people out they will also help
you out just overall I've never not been
helped when I've ever been to a city
just straight up yeah
yeah so yeah tap into the hot breath of
us is a great way
um for sure there Mookie
yeah
um
next question and also if you're going
to a town you can also just like cold
call cold email venues that maybe are
doing music or karaoke or other things
and you can just reach out and ask if
they would want to do a comedy show as
well if you have like zero leads in that
City or you can poetry open mics you can
perform at other types of open mics I've
performed at poetry open mics Music open
mics karaoke like I performed anywhere
there's a microphone so if you really
want that stage time that's another
route that's also accessible to you yeah
I also think it's smart to like find the
information of the Bookers of the comedy
clubs in the city that you're going to
and just send them like hey I'll be in
town this weekend I was wondering if I
can get a feature set or if I can get a
couple of minutes on stage or again yeah
or I guess a guess set yeah and Cinema
tape and you know
it has worked for me I've had people be
like oh yeah this is great
um and then it also helps if you've got
someone who could vouch for you too uh
if they know someone uh not that it's
needed but if you do that's always
helpful someone who can vouch for you in
those comedy groups in that have like oh
I'm coming to Atlanta or I'm coming to
San Diego there's always people that'll
be like vouch hey this guy is absolutely
hilarious those help I book comedians
off those things all the time if we've
got like just people in the city I've
booked them for the shows that we've we
do together if I know you're coming in
town for that weekend and you want to
get up on stage for sure I'll look
through and be like I'll watch because
you know some of our shows are clean
clean shows so I want to make sure that
you can actually do a clean Set uh and I
will book you for that show and I think
there's other other Bookers that'll do
the exact same thing and the more heads
up the better I know as comedians we can
wait to the last minute or the last hour
you know even I'm guilty of that as well
but the more heads up you can give the
the higher your chances are going to be
to find a show for sure and this is
coming from someone who is very guilty
of waiting last minute for things like
that so yeah that's a good question yeah
great question
um all roads lead back to the hot breath
averse uh
uh I crack myself up any secrets to a
solid open mic
uh
um not really sure if that's is that for
performing or do you think that's for
like producing
we'll just take it from the
each side we'll go performing and we'll
go producing uh for performing I think
it's just preparation just prepare and
practice what you are going to do and I
think whatever happens at the open mic
will happen but I think just
you know I think you and I do this we
over prepare for things to make sure
that when we get there
like we were prepared and the likelihood
is whatever we prepared isn't what's
going to happen but we were prepared for
the best and I think that's just an
important factor when you want to go
into an open mic from a performance
perspective
yeah he said producing
um what do you followed up with yeah
for an open mic I mean a few I mean open
mic is kind of the wild west but I mean
a few things are just setting up the
show to win like having something as
simple as the chairs facing the stage
um kind of like even in the show Yoshi
United Thursday between where this mic
was set up and where the audience was
there was a big gap so we moved where
the mic was and made us the center of
the room and then it became like it was
perfect and we performed at that venue a
few times this was the first time we
moved there best setup yet best show
we've had yet most tips we've had yet
yeah and I think it's just recognizing
where people can Garner the most
attention where can most people follow
their eyes towards you as the comedians
or towards the stage just think of it as
like you have to have everyone's
attention it's important to when
possible if possible turn off TVs behind
you so no one is distracted when they
are looking at you turn off music if
there's music playing like bars are just
doing what bars do or breweries or
whatever it may be
ask them to turn off those sounds so
they have your full attention when you
are giving them a show and it's what you
are giving them uh more than anything
else is that okay we're doing comedy
from this time to this time and so it's
just important just to take out any kind
of distractions as much as possible the
other element is also make sure you
remind people
uh to
um tip if you're doing a tip show remind
people that this is how you give money
to the comics remind people to get
drinks uh remind people to actually like
do the thing that the bar wants which is
drink uh I think that's helpful I think
I'm probably given like a lot of Hosting
stuff as well but there's just like
elements of reminding people about the
venue reminding people to think tip
their waiters this is important for all
clubs and they remind people to go to
like the website to check out the more
shows tell people when you'll be back I
think is an important thing as well so
they know oh we've got friends that
would love to have seen this when's the
next time you're going to have a show I
think is a super important thing to do
for an open mic and even I mean even for
a show but even for an open mic hey we
do this every week or we do this every
two weeks or every third Thursday or
every third Friday whatever it may be
just a reminder to people that this is
what you're doing and then
um start on time as well yeah yeah start
on time is a big one and if you're not
going to start on time make the
announcement
at the start time of the show of like
welcome everyone we're gonna start a few
minutes late thank you all so much for
being here feel free to grab a drink or
just get comfortable we're gonna start
here in just a few minutes thank you for
coming so if starting on time is crucial
but but if you don't start on time at
least when the show is supposed to start
make sure you go up there make an
announcement welcome people let them
know what's what's up that's crucial for
retention and people coming back and
telling their friends and family to come
as well yeah because a lot of people
there's I mean not a lot of people but
some people are very uh time conscious
right if you don't say anything they're
wondering what is happening
so it's just good just to say something
before they're like well is this gonna
happen because then people just might
leave like they might not think it's
gonna happen if you don't tell them oh
this is going to start in a couple of
minutes so yeah that's a really good
exactly yeah that's a big one we're
waiting for more people to get here just
to start for the people that are there
at least let the respect the people that
are there on time to let them know the
deal and don't start late if at all
possible yes
uh yeah
um
um Cyrus
Zed
from up in Toronto
as the when did you guys
make the tradition a full-time comedians
ah gosh I think mine was
seven or eight I need to look back I
know it was six seven or eight years in
maybe seven to eight years in
I was working refilling mini bars living
in the hood of Atlanta in a studio
apartment saved up a nest egg
um oh what I did was I was working
Enterprise Rent-A-Car
living in the hood of Atlanta saved up a
nest egg then started refilling many
bars so I took a lesser paying job that
gave me more flexibility to pursue
comedy more
so I kind of eased into comedy that way
I didn't just dive in blind I like saved
up a nest egg took a lesser paying job
that had more flexibility and had free
food so when I would do Road gigs I
would have all these expired mini bar
foods that I could eat I I lived on
Cliff Bars for a week straight
um that's a No Cap
um
or regularity no cap or regularity uh
um it was like we call that the mud tour
but
um
so I ease into it that way and I had a
nest egg and as comedy got a little
busier I like sat down and was like all
right what is the best case scenario me
quitting my job and pursuing comedy
full-time what is the worst case
scenario and I weighed the options and
was like am I willing to live with the
worst case scenario and I was like yes
so then from there I took the leap so I
kind of did a gradual saved up and then
took lesser paying jobs with more
flexibility and eased into it that way
so I would say seven or eight years in I
would say I like I waited till I had
a show worth paying for as well like I
waited till I was like all right I think
I'm good enough for people to pay to see
me and make a living out of this
nice uh yeah I think uh mine was last
late last year around like September
October time so that was about seven and
a half years in
um and I think so my journey was a
little different because I went full
time about a year one and a half in like
I was a year it's a comedy and uh at the
time my wife was working full-time and I
was like I just got into comment I was
like babe this is it this is the thing I
want to go all in kind of thing so a
year and a half in after just killing
the open mic saying I was killing open
mics but not doing a lot of book shows I
was still doing a couple book shows
definitely not getting paid for it
uh to any extent I was mostly getting
paid in exposure and uh gas money at
this time so like uh I went in like a
year and a half in and then about two
years and I was like oh this is not a
good idea uh because I didn't really
know anything about comedy
and then you know fast forward year
three four five six seven I went back to
work while I was doing comedy on the
side and then yeah last year I made the
leap and
uh when I made the leap I you know I
already had money saved and I was just
like hey let me see what happens if I go
all in on this and
that's when I did it and you know I'm a
married man with kids and I made sure
that it was all good with the wifey uh
and make sure that you know we had the
nest egg to sort of dip into while I'm
still getting paid some in tater tots
but you know the money started flowing
in and to your point I definitely did it
at a point where I felt like I had a
product and I had a product that I can
take on the road like I feel like I've
got an hour that I can headline with go
on the road do a couple of shows and be
good like I can do a weekend really at
any spot
um and so that's kind of when I made the
leap like okay I've got something that
is marketable and I can take anywhere
any City I've got the stuff uh to make
it happen so that's when I made my LEAP
was about seven and a half years in
yeah and it's all personal it's all
personal preference like it's really
kind of what you're willing your
lifestyle to be in a certain sense I
mean I had friends who jumped in very
early and were sleeping on the floor of
like a two-bedroom apartment with like
five other people in it type deal you
know like it's all kind of what you want
to do you can do it whenever you want
just based on what kind of lifestyle you
want to live basically you know so um
yeah we took both we took a little more
of the I guess methodical thoughtful
route but there's no really right or
wrong way I will say
when comedy becomes your full-time gig
it can very easily if you're not careful
take all the fun out of it because now
this is your livelihood now this is your
way to get food on the table like it it
adds another layer of pressure Beyond
just oh we're doing comedy telling
sillies hanging out maybe getting a few
drink tickets this is awesome type deal
you know so do be mindful of that when
comedy does become your full-time gig
it's very glamorous you know we know
full-time comedians that live in their
cars as well so there's
full-time comedy is very vague from
Sebastian Maniscalco selling out Madison
Square Garden for a month
to a comedian living in their car going
open mic to open mic so
sure just it's kind of what you want out
of your own career and what you're
willing to live with basically and being
honest and transparent with yourself
because there is there's no rush I will
tell you this I mean you can
yeah they're they're you can be you can
be discovered too soon but you can't be
discovered too late so you're not
missing out by not blowing up quote
unquote blowing up within like a year or
two and it taking you 15 years or 20
years where Nate bargatzi is now selling
out arenas
but he's been doing it over 20 years to
get there so it's all kind of personal
preference and what you're willing to do
and what you want out of your own career
as well yeah
yeah I would just say make sure that the
people around you uh are supportive
because comedy is a lonely business so
you want to make sure that there's
plenty of that you get a lot of support
and I'd say try not to go at this alone
if possible where you know if you're
living in your car and you are like sort
of solar sort of a solo person really
like I know comedians that every city
that they're in they reach out to comics
in that City like hey you got a cow
truck and crash I think that's smart to
do that uh and that way you're also
expanding your network of people that
you get to know as well
um
exactly yep and if you're married it's
being completely transparent with your
spouse about this topic and this
discussion and what it looks like and or
if you're dating someone like you know
letting them know hey I'm gonna be out
at open mics before my wife moved down
here and we moved in together I told her
like this is this is what I do this is
what my lifestyle looks like I'm gone
like every night or I'm gone all weekend
type deal like I was just very
transparent and honest and that
transparency will help alleviate any
stressor worry down the line because you
let your spouse or significant other
know that this is part of the gig this
is what this is what I uh signed up for
type deal
yep
so yeah it's all personal preference
that's ours
um Jacob himself on YouTube is roasting
me said I look like I look like the
governor of California I look like
Snoopy I look like Tucker Carlson I mean
all facts but I mean come on I mean the
saddest
you know like game here
but Jacob's profile picture is of him
holding his child so honestly out of
I feel like whatever state Jacob lives
in I feel like the authorities are gonna
have the last laugh with him and I don't
want to roast him you know I'm above
that I'm out of that game
I've been there I've done that
I don't want to roast anymore I I think
life is roasting Jacob enough that he
has a child and he is spending valuable
time after their school the child's out
of school now this is this is 6 p.m this
is Prime Time family time and Jacob is
on YouTube
roasting meat and that's on him that's
on him dfacs will find him they'll roast
him
alimony
sent us a super chat so just disregard
everything we've ever said about Jacob
there we go
money heals all wounds
there you go
thank you Jacob himself we appreciate
that buddy
all right
man don't make me don't make me
flashback Yoshi these kids don't know
they don't know they don't know the
comedy hype rooftop roasts
see that's an old me that's old me they
gonna make me go back to the old me the
Devil is a Lie they gonna make me
backslide on here yo I'm trying to
I'm dry bar Joel now I'm clean you know
what I'm saying but that always trying
to pull a brother back they try to pull
a brother back you know just when you
get out they try to bring you back in
[Laughter]
they don't know y'all don't
y'all don't even know why don't don't
make me get white boy Joel out here
[Laughter]
to go in fam they don't even seen
something
boy
they don't even know
oh and they ain't gonna know cause I
want to get booked
[Laughter]
I don't even know about they don't even
know about my rabbit past I used to be
rabbit out in these streets
um
because we're starting to land This
Plane here let me see
um
Chris Summers asked a few questions we
like to just ask answer one
um
uh let's see he said we already he said
best city starting out we talked about
that on a previous show
um if you have 300 pages of material how
would you go sifting through condensing
it to five seven twenty minutes
um diverse twin guys who make it to
those who get stuck at open mics for 10
to 20 years
how do you find your persona so he asked
that one first
um
uh I feel like the most relevant for
people listening is gonna be the the
Persona one maybe
yeah yeah let's let's do that one
because I mean the diff like the people
who make it out of the open mic circuit
next to get on the road and stuff and
that just comes down to being proactive
I mean that really just comes down to
people who are willing to like
some people just get stuck in open mics
they use it as a social scene and
they're just out getting drunk after
every show and they use it more as like
a hangout which if that's what you want
to do fine but if you want to become a
professional comedian you got to treat
it like a job and really
be grinded on stage
um and networking and such like we
talked about last week but treating it
like a job being professional I think
those who get stuck at open mics just do
the same jokes every single week at the
same places every single week and they
just get comfortable
um finding your persona though I mean
it comes down to writing what's personal
to you at the end of the day like
Persona is like personal so writing
about your life writing about what
interests you writing about I was just
Angela Johnson just released a new
special on YouTube and I just listened
back to her hot breath interview that we
did together today and she talked about
finding your voice as like diving into
things that are personal to you
childhood experiences things that
embarrass you things that excite you
things that confuse you things that you
have a personal emotional attachment to
that's where you're going to start to
talk about these topics from your most
natural state and that's where your
persona will Bloom from
yeah I mean I think the Persona question
is it's a good one and it's a
complicated one but I'll say one way to
find out sort of
where your persona is from an audience
perspective not that like the audience
is the validating element
but when you're doing like your jokes
and people are telling you sort of hey
this is what people would let you know
what they liked versus what they not
necessarily what they don't like but
like what really resonated with them
and what I found that what I got a lot
of feedback on was like Hey I really
like your dad material or hey yeah what
about the kid stuff was hilarious hey
that HOA joke really really hit
that
as I've like looked at my material and
like was developing it I was like oh
that's because I'm talking about the
things that I'm going through
and that's how you sort of refine like
hey what's sort of the thing that you
are doing and the Persona that you are
coming off across
and being comfortable with that Persona
I'm good with being a dad being good
with living out in the suburbs and good
with talking about the HOA because that
is exactly what I am where it kind of
like rubber meets the road is if you
don't like the stuff that you're talking
about and you want to change it or you
don't like like the material that you're
saying just doesn't feel like you then
you just gotta find more ways to like
talk about the daily things that you go
through like what kind of things are you
going through on a normal basis I think
uh John cosma we're going to screw his
name up kuzma forever and yeah he even
booked Us in Charleston uh in a few
months and we still got his name wrong
what's that Cosmo uh yeah he talked
about really like what kind of moments
that you have that was one of the things
I liked about his uh his interview he
was like what moments do you have
throughout your day like what are the
moments that sort of are happening in
your day that most people may not have
or they're very very unique to you and
capture those within your comedy capture
those in your Clips capture those for
your audience
um and see how that resonates with your
material so I think it's just important
to take note of what people find funny
take note of what people remember as
well and then also take note of what you
feel good about and I think sort of that
combination will help you find your
persona
yeah I think paying attention to how
your funny off stage as well
is very important of is it is it your
sarcasm is it your silliness is it
you're like is it your roasting is it
your cutting remarks like is it certain
do you speak a certain way do you speak
with a certain vocabulary or something
like paying attention to how you're
funny off stage and starting to
translate that onto stage is how a lot
of people also find their Persona and
also take all this information with the
reality that it takes time to
make all of this happen so you're aware
of how to find your persona
and the process of actually developing
and cultivating your persona is being on
stage as much as possible now that
you're aware of talking about these
personal things or things that you're
funny off stage with and taking them on
stage and just gradually working through
them on stage and you'll start to find
what does resonate with the audience
that you can then build upon so what do
you think about
um I've had this question asked before
Comics who talk about trying to find
their Persona like as soon as they start
stand up
because I think I have a different take
because I think you should learn how to
write jokes and figure out joke telling
and just the art of joke writing and
telling before you try to find your
persona of just writing like getting
into the habit of jokes what are your
thoughts on that
yeah for me I think the first thing you
have to figure out before you can figure
out personas you have to figure out how
to make something funny
like you need to understand you you
almost have to you have to learn the
rules before you break them so I I
believe you do have to learn how to
write a joke how to get consistent
laughs on stage because once you build
up the confidence and that skill set
that's when you get the stage confidence
to start exploring and being more
vulnerable on stage and being able to
actually listen to the audience and
actually start to develop with the
audience for so early in your career
you're literally just like I gotta get
this next word out to this punchline
regardless of what happens type deal
you're not having a you're not having a
dialogue with the audience you're
literally just like doing a monologue
just hoping you don't like pee
everywhere
I do believe you first need to learn how
to just make your dog funny or make the
news like a headline funny I think you
do need to learn the fundamentals and
then you can start to spend them and
apply them to your own personal style
and preference but you know I mean for
probably the first five years I was just
like all one-liners I just learned how
to write a one-liner and just hammered
it home over and over and over again
until it developed like a set where I
was getting consistent laughs and could
start to grow from there it's dude it I
I don't want to burst anyone's bubble
but from all the interviews I've done
everyone has said it takes like 10 years
to figure out even who you are yeah it
takes you 10 years on stage to figure
out who like who you are and then it
takes another five years to figure out
what you want to talk about and then
from there the fun starts so
I don't want to hurt anyone's feelings
but like after interviewing over 400
Comedians and after being in comedy 13
years and I would say the pandemic kind
of took two years of that away but I can
say yeah I'm just now like getting into
like oh this is kind of my style on
stage so what do I want to do with it
you know and I'm still learning I've
interviewed people 20 years in that say
they're still learning but it take it
takes time dude so just learning first
and I think one thing especially around
your persona is to like I think it's
important as a comedian to have fun on
stage yes so you get to figure out like
how you're received by the audience like
I'm thinking about the set that we just
did this weekend
like as I was going through like my
prepared material there was literally
kids running around at this place
yeah with no shirts on yeah with no
shirts on just like just just free range
kids just running around this place and
I didn't just keep going on my jokes I
just went to material I was like oh I've
got one of those free-range kids and it
just helped me sort of like ground that
and then I made a joke about I literally
asked this little girl what her name was
and it just like made the show much more
organic when she told me her name and I
made fun about how like something about
how I thought your name would be Keisha
but her name was Grace and how that
would be great for if she was an ally
and if her parents were an ally they
would have named her Keisha rather than
Grace so like just being in that moment
of just accepting things as they were
that was me playing my dad that was me
playing dad and being comfortable with
who I am just seeing kids run around and
sort of going into a natural motive what
is this kid doing let me interact with
this kid or else they're going to
disturb the show in the way that they
want I'd rather control The Narrative of
what's gonna happen before they go do
something so I think it's important to
also just be like a uh uh what's the
word just be like have fun on stage like
that's so important to also just have
fun on stage and that's how you'll find
yourself and find your persona
um when you're doing comedy
yep for sure
um we're running out of time here so
let's set up the timer let's do a quick
um for these last few let's just do a
quick lightning Round Here
uh because I want to get to them because
zaynova said you guys rock thank you in
advance and I just I want to you know I
want to get to them
um so
um zainova asked and we'll keep it to a
minute we'll do this lightning round how
did you guys
used to go about structuring a five
minute set in the beginning I'm on the
open mic Circ in LA and want to fuse my
jokes together better
you guys rock thanks in advance
so
well don't say so and then pause we have
60 seconds you just gave this thoughtful
pause and now I'm distracting it into no
no no let me start the timer for you
there say Nova okay I'm gonna set I
think it's important that if you've got
in a five minute set I'd say you
probably have five to six maybe seven
jokes I would say is sort of typical
five to seven uh jokes that you have
maybe right in terms of just jokes in
terms of actual topics for you to say a
setup say a punchline say some tags
whatever it may be
I think it's important that the
structure be your second best joke goes
first your best joke goes last
everything in between you can organize
based on how you are telling your jokes
I think it's important that your jokes
go in some kind of order if you're
talking about like when I used to be a
kid and now I'm an adult don't do the
adult thing first and then do the kid
thing later just do the kid thing first
and then do the adult thing sort of
later I think it's important to
structure things in a good timeline if
that's how your jokes are structured but
if you're doing a showcase set just try
to do things that get the most laughs
just out out the gate so work on really
what in your five minute set get you the
most laughs I would say that's how you
structure sort of your good five minute
set
yeah um well Yoshi took up all the time
but
yeah the Transitions and segues between
joke to joke can come organically over
time you just first want to focus on
like what is a joke I know gets a laugh
all right let's open with that what is a
joke I know gets a laugh let's close
with that so you want to open with a
laugh within hopefully 15-20 seconds and
then you want to end with a laugh and
then anything else in between you can
make it
based on topic all right I'm talking
about my family for the first minute or
two I have all my family jokes in this
section and then I have all my like my
job jokes in the middle and at the end
maybe dating or whatnot so you can
organize them based on topic as well
that'll make a little more organic but
the audience doesn't
if it doesn't flow completely
conversationally from top of the topic
they're just listening for jokes so you
don't have to overthink that aspect
those the Segways usually come more
organically
perfect
yeah all right
um Cinema Quirk they already ask one
the Cinemark one
well they basically asked did um is
Rogan's Mothership the new Comedy Store
well as someone that's been there
not to brag
yeah it is 100 the new Comedy Store
um yeah did you perform there or did you
just go
I just went I just went and watched I
did not perform there but it yeah not
yet not working on it I got in for free
if that helps I got to go hang out in
mitzi's bar
if that helps I got recognized by a hot
Brethren if that helps yeah yeah and
while we were there and then a hot
Brethren is a door guy there who
actually who actually didn't mean it
no CJ Landry oh Tony's not a Tony
Hinchcliffe is not a door guy there
sorry Casius Tony Casius no no no no no
CJ Landry
um
uh nice
um but yeah it it all the hype is true
about that place
um
any thoughts on showcases where Comics
introduced the next comic instead of
having a host slash MC
I think it's for no I mean for an open
mic I think it's fine for one comic to
introduce the next
um for a showcase I would I would
definitely prefer to
see um a host go up now that being said
speaking of Mothership the shows I
watched just one comedian introduced the
next one there wasn't a host that went
up in between each one so it can help
the show flow more but I think for a
showcase Vibe I like there to be a host
yeah yeah I mean I think uh I've seen it
done where comedians
um bring on the next person where I've
seen an issue is that comedians forget
who the next person coming up is or they
kind of pause and like oh who's coming
up next or they'll ask somebody else
who's coming up next and so it can pop
it can make the experience a little
awkward so I would say hopefully that
the comedians have done that before and
introduce the next one makes it much
easier to do
big facts
nice all right
yeah well we did it
he done did it we did it
thank you everyone for hanging out
absolutely
that Angela Johnson special solid
yeah yeah yeah yeah I watched it today
yeah we're gonna have um we're gonna
have Chris come on and do a breakdown of
it
um yeah he actually got he actually got
caught up we're gonna have him come on
today
um like the weather's really bad right
now he said in Texas and there was like
really bad traffic so um and
and Chris is also a family man who has
real life responsibilities that will
come on here from time to time for free
after analyzing comedy specials for free
you know so he had another member of the
hopper at the verse who's in it For the
Love of the Game I can't wait to be
paying everyone a part of this including
myself and
get paid in exposure and Love Explosion
but in the meantime between time Yoshi
and I are available for bookings let's
talk just this weekend I'm performing
I'm headlining a comedy club Blue Ridge
comedy club in Bristol Tennessee all
weekend thanks to hot brother and Phil
ketron so reach out to us and let's
let's work together
absolutely yeah thank you guys this has
been fun love and uh just a reminder we
will not be here for the next two weeks
uh probably uh three weeks actually we
pre-recorded
three quick episodes where we give you
like the five top tips based on our most
uh asked questions we get so we'll be
releasing those every week for the next
few weeks on the podcast so do be sure
to check those out and share them with
your fellow comedians as we are gone
I'll be out of town
but we will be back in a few weeks but
until then
we love you all in between time holla
holla holla holla
we love you all thank you all for
hanging out
join our email list to be up to date on
all the cool things we're doing here
join our Facebook group to be a part of
our daily writing contest
and we'll see y'all
in a few weeks we love you all
bye y'all
bye
breath